nakamura managed to win the second match
and you know what that means that means
that we have some
blitz games and eventually armageddon at
our uh
at our hands and um this is a blitz game
nakamura needs to win because legrov
won the first blitz game so if nakamura
draws or loses
he is out of uh the tournament so there
is another camera with high pressure on
his shoulders here
against uh lagrange so let's see how the
game
went d4 certainly is slightly surprising
knowing that we have seen e4 mostly from
uh nakamura
but all right knight of six from uh
lagravi wants to play his
gurren feld with g6 and d5
his uh his pet line but then nakamura
surprises us and he plays bishop g5
which is the trompowsky it's certainly
an interesting
uh try i'm sure he just wanted a
position with no particular theory or
whatsoever although there is some some
theory here
i think he just wanted to surprise maxim
a bit considering that this is a blitz
game
it does make some sense to just get a
position
and take it from there because the
theoretical
theoretical duel in the gruenfeld is
definitely going to benefit maxime who
is a huge
expert on that field d5 from
maxine e3 c5
fairly reminiscent play from uh from
black of uh
of the london defense very standard to
to play c5 and challenge the center here
c3 from nakamura queen b6 queen c1
and indeed it more or less would have
been in london if the bishop was on
on f4 but it is on g5 which
makes a slight difference although not
very huge bishop f5 from metallica
is a logical move developing the bishop
knight d2
keep in mind that this is blitz so they
are playing very fast here
97 knight f3 and e6 both sides are
developing logically and i must say
uh lagrav has a nice position already he
is
probably even slightly better definitely
not slightly worse
but it is blitz so anything can happen
knight h4 from nakamura he wants to take
this
uh beautiful light squared bishop here
and the legra plays bishop b4
this makes sense because now it's not
ideal to take
at all in fact it it more or less loses
after knight takes c4
not the bishop f4 g5 by the fork
but in general it's not really ideal
anyway because d
takes e4 is always quite unpleasant
because of the fact that this knight
hangs
in many lines with h6 g5 but
uh here it doesn't work by tactical
reasons as i mentioned
but just to keep keep that in mind a4
a typical move you want to play a5 and
chase away the queen
also bishop b5 is sometimes in
the air asx is another logical way to
to counter that no no bishop e5 now
bishop e2 instead h6 and the bishop is
now forced to take on the f6 so this is
not really that great for
for white g5 could come eventually
uh black has a nice position and
legrove all he needs now is uh is a draw
and then he
is going to going to play against wesley
so i believe
but is it going to manage to hold the
draw that is the question and we're
going to see soon
so knight takes c4 d takes e4 and now g5
is a threat so nakamura is more or less
forced to play g3
giving the knight the g2 square here
this should be seven uh lagrav doesn't
want to play g5 which is fairly
understandable but
it certainly is a logical try and simply
continue like this
can't be bad and then castle even queen
side but white's pieces are
very poorly placed then i think black's
doing well of course black can also
castle
uh king side here but that's slightly
more risky when you play g5
however there should be seven as i said
castles
and more than ever now than ever uh
now more than ever um g5 and
h5 is fairly possible chief
followed by h5 h4 could potentially be
uh
be a way to go although this sharpens
the game
significantly and keeping in mind that
legrav he needs only a draw to
to go to the semifinals this is probably
not a good idea so that is why he
settled for the more quiet castles css
better position and no risk in the
slightest here so queen c2
rook c8 attacking on d4 so white is
forced to defend that with the rook here
rook d8 rook c1
it's not possible to take any longer
because the rook protects the queen
so c c takes d4 e takes c4
and now rook takes c4 has decided it's
not possible because we take simply take
back
and the rook protects the queen so
knight d5 from uh legrove and maurice
now
equalized he is white so it's not such a
big deal but
95 is slightly inaccurate although it is
a logical move
so he plays 95 and then followed by f5
which is you know slightly risky
because if i one day get to play f3 and
i open up the e file here it's gonna be
very weak
against the pawn on e6 and that is
something you do not really want
but did nakamura exploit that queen b1
from nakamura and um
i don't like that move my old coach as
i've said before
backward moves are always bad and
and here black has an excellent position
instead maybe
simply play something like king h1 or f3
as i already mentioned
i think that would have been slightly
better but i guess nakamura was afraid
of something like bishop g5 and knight
e3 where it's going to be
very difficult to win he might hold the
game but he's not going to win and he
needs a victory
so he plays queen v1 bishop g5 rook c2
and look at his awkward placed pieces
here
very awkward every single piece and
white black has an excellent position
after the move queen b3
attacking the pawn on a4 here and things
are turning
more and more difficult from for hikaru
nakamura
desperately needs a victory so can he do
it
he plays a5 but now knight b4 is coming
and lagrav is winning an exchange here
so rook c1 is forced bishop takes c1
rook takes c1 and the computer gives an
edge of minus three for the graph
which is not surprising considering the
fact that he is an exchange
up can nakamura bounce back
remember the draw is not enough for him
he needs to win
so knight d5 f3 takes takes
at least this is fairly desirable now i
can play rookie one and put some
pressure on e6
but of course we're down material things
are not looking too great
queen b5 from uh legrove rookie one
putting some pressure on e6
rook e8 and the advantage has already
gone down a little bit
so the advantage is not more than minus
one till
1.5 still huge advantage but it's not
so easy because suddenly i'm starting to
have tactics here
before example rook takes e6 followed by
bishop to e5
in some lines let's say if i play rook
queen a2
that's nakamura did here rook takes e6
is a threat you have to be careful of
and after king h8 the position is all of
a sudden
equal after the move bishop h5 which is
absolutely crazy considering the fact
that the computer
gave minus three just a few moves ago
and that's what happens when you play
blitz
everything can change out of nowhere
things are all of a sudden entirely
different
and i do believe lagrave was very
nervous at this point like
uh there's something that happens to you
psychologically when you know that you
have
that you have a winning position but you
realize that you've started to mess
everything up and it makes you angry
usually and then you play slightly worse
because you are angry
happens to me a lot and it's quite
common especially in blitz
and um yeah let's see how the game
continued rook e7 and after knight h4
black is under severe pressure despite
being an exchange up so now knight g6 is
a threat knight f5 is a threat in some
cases for example king g8 knight xf5
have a crushing position for right for
white because you cannot take it because
then i take the rook and the knight here
is pinned by the queen on a2
who all of a sudden has showed up as we
did see
earlier with queen a2 so king h7
is played and that is a bad move from
lagrave
who once again falls for the tactics and
the position
so instead he had to play the sad move
rook e8
and just accept that he had
blundered and after rook takes rook
takes the position is
probably fairly equal and remember there
is no c4
because i can play queen b4
attacking the rook on e1 and uh
yeah it could might even be better oh
sorry i'm uh playing about uh
messing up a little bit um it might have
even
be been better here to play bishop f7 to
keep things complicated instead of
trading on e8
because the white light square bishop is
very strong
but king h7 happened and now the
beautiful move
bishop g6 would have more or less uh
led to a winning advantage here but
remember this is blitz and nakamura
plays knight g6
just quickly showing that after bishop
g6 king h8 the ship text f5 would have
been possible
because of knight g6 and 67 and if black
would play king g8 knight takes f5 it
would have been possible
similar to what i showed you earlier
so knight g6 rook c7 this is a bad move
best move here would have been to play
rookie 8 and after something like 95
rookie 7 the position is still very
complicated
uh but objectively it is even
so rook c7 rook 95 i'm a bit unsure why
um
why nakamura did not take the pawn on e6
uh surprises me a little bit but i'm
sure he found something he didn't like
something like night before that is kind
of an annoying move to get against you
because you cannot take the rook because
of rook c1 is made
pretty much instantly that is something
that you cannot allow
then you would have to play something
like queen b1 or a queen a3
but then knight d3 is possible and
there's a lot of tricks here and a lot
of things to watch out for and
when you're playing blitz it's
unpleasant so 95 makes sense
king g8 from uh legrove he now controls
the f7 square
and he controls most of the stuff in
this diagonal as well
so maybe he has gotten things under
control and
indeed the computer things he is
slightly better here
knight g6 from nakamura king h7 and this
is a poor
move because now now uh lagrav has
allowed nakamura to um to take the pawn
on
e6 i guess they just uh they were moving
back and forth here
for some reason i didn't i didn't notice
that instantly
but um well the only difference is that
the rook is
on c7 yeah i guess he uh he thought that
he uh
he has control but apparently it's not
as simple as he
thought so um
yeah a better move simply protect the
pawn on e6 with queen d7
and black is still doing well although
the position
is very complicated a lot more
complicated than it should have been
but it is blitz so king h7 rook takes e6
and things are looking good now for a
kikari nakamura who needs a victory in
order to stay in this match and can he
do it
knight of six from malagrav attacking
the bishop on h5
bishop e2 attacking the queen queen d5
now
and things are looking harder and harder
for maksim vashir lagrav here
who probably should have played queen d7
but after that knight e5 is looking
quite obnoxious but after queen b1 and
94
he still has a finger in the game like
he um
it's not over yet he can also put the
queen on g5 protect on f5
he's under severe pressure and it's
extremely difficult to defend in
practice it might not even be possible
to defend
but it is a better try than queen t5
although queen d5 is a very logical way
to try to defend
taking the queen and bishop d3 is very
strong because now the part on
g f5 will probably fall
because after rook f7 we can play knight
e5
it's like a mirror does and then d6
i'm sure g4 was possible at some point
maybe in the previous move
like here this looks like a possible try
to me
because if i take back 97 comes and i
win the
rook on c8 or even the knight on d5
nice choice there so g4 is very possible
if you have to play something like
rook f6 that wouldn't really work
because the bishop takes a five and
there's too many threats here this would
be
winning for for right after for example
rook takes c6
knight f4 and then bishop takes e6
attacking the knight
and and rook but 95 was played
rookie fade rook 26 93
rook d7 and it's very difficult for
allah look at that beautiful knight on
e5 look at these
pawns here look at the pod on a5 look at
all of these weak pawns
this is a very difficult position to
defend and
indeed the computer gives an advantage
of more than
plus three for hikaru nakamura so rook
b8
rook d6 from nakamura
a little bit surprising but of course
again it's blitz which is probably
something i've said
five times already the best move would
have been to play
g4 which is a computer move uh you're
just going to take the pawn on f5
and the things are far too weak uh
around the black
king rook d6 was played
rook c8 rook b6 rook c7
king f2 from nakamura pushes away
tonight on e3
knight t5 attacking the rook on b6 rook
d6
97 and here 97 attacking
the rook but he also wants to jump to c5
and maybe e6
as well so rook f7 knight c5
and he has great control over
everything here like rob just has to
wait knight c6
b4 look at this great pawn chain right
here
very very strong pawn chain beautiful
knight on c5
great bishop on d3 g6 here protecting f5
h4 now with the plan of h5
legra plays knight e7 bishop c4
attacking the rook rook g7
should be three knight e6 could become a
threat but you got to be careful so you
do not lose the pawn on c3
rook c6 rook d7 knight c8 it is starting
to look
very very bad for lagrange takes on g7
kings takes g7 bishop to e5 and
um the rook moves to um
to c7 but after rook c7 the fork knight
e6 decides the game
black blunders the rook but no matter if
he had played something like rook d6
bishop takes b7 knight a7 and bishop
takes a6 is completely winning because
of all of these
these pawns very unfortunate for lagrava
could have decided to match here
he was so close if we go back a little
bit the position after
queen b1 and here the position is
absolutely hopeless for for nakamura but
he got a lot of compensation here and
the best move for black would have been
to play a b6 and just get rid of this
pawn because this pawn is quite strong
it takes
some nice squares but more importantly
when you play b6 here
you do open up the b file as well which
is quite significant because when you
are a rook up
or an exchange up you want to utilize
those rooks and those rooks are not very
effective if they do not really have any
squares and open files
but if they do they they are much better
than the bishops or knights
but if they do not they can quickly
become inferior to the
bishops and knights as we did see in the
game and if we go
forward if you move the position is
already equal after just three moves
and in this position the computer can
say minus one
or plus one or whatever black has made
it significantly
more complicated for himself and of
course as it is a blitz game it's very
difficult in practice
so well executed by nakamura there and
he
is going to be playing wesley
so and the semi final
stay tuned for that